sabes lo que es genial de las ciencias
de la computación y de la programación
de computadoras bueno ya sabes además de
todo hay muchísimos puestos de trabajo y
campos interesantes que usan
conocimientos de computación y esos
números están creciendo cada día en esta
serie entrevistamos a algunas personas
que trabajan en computación para ganarse
la vida para saber lo que hacen cómo
aprenden y cuáles son sus consejos para
los que son nuevos en este campo
puedes leer sobre sara northwave que es
una desarrolladora independiente de
juegos y viajera del mundo yang dauphine
que investiga sobre el aprendizaje de
las máquinas y toca el bajo prenda gym
creadora de prototipos de tabletas para
macys y en en bicicleta por las colinas
de san francisco tom reina que crea
aplicaciones médicas para móviles y los
fines de semana aprende a ser piloto
marcos ojeda un diseñador de khan
academy desarrollador y dueño de un
perro y muchos más así que continúa
conoce algunos profesionales y si
todavía no eres profesional en
computación piénsalo puede ser muy
divertido